let's talk a little bit about the matt
gates
scandal the matt gates scandal broke
while we were
on vacation last week republican
congressman matt gates is under
investigation
for a whole bunch of things including
possible child sex
trafficking matt gates after word of
this investigation came out
appeared on fox news with tucker carlson
last week i guess to plead his innocence
but he ended up
actually sort of further incriminating
himself even at one point saying to
tucker tucker don't you remember you
went to dinner with me and a girl i was
with and tucker claimed
i don't know what you're talking about i
mean you couldn't script a more bizarre
story and now we are starting to get
into the phase of
how serious could the crimes matt gates
may be accused of be when it comes to
consequences well dave ehrenberg
who's a state attorney for palm beach
county florida was on msnbc yesterday
explaining that child sex trafficking
one of the
possible crimes gates could be charged
with it can come
with a penalty of life in prison take a
look at this video
goal liability that gates is facing here
we just ran through quite a few
very distasteful things which of them
may end up being crimes that matt gates
could be charged with
well good morning casey the most serious
crime is child sex
trafficking which is punishable by up to
life in prison and there is a 10-year
mandatory minimum
and the more information that comes out
the fewer defenses
matt seems to have left because joel
greenberg the former tax collector of
seminole county
is being charged with child sex
trafficking over the same 17 year old
girl
at issue so the point here is not for me
to tell you
ooh matt gates might end up in prison
for life
i'm not telling you i believe matt gates
is going to end up with life in prison
the point here is that what matt gates
is wrapped
up in could come with a sentence of life
in prison now
matt gates is a privileged member of
congress one of 435
he will get top-notch defense attorneys
there's no way in hell
that matt gates at the tail end of this
ends up with life in prison but the
point is
a normal person might be at risk of life
in prison based on what
matt gates is being investigated for
doing meanwhile
every time matt gates tries to explain
why he's not guilty of anything
he seems to raise more questions and
further incriminate himself
in the tucker carlson interview last
week gates uh said
i've never paid anyone for sex and at
that time that wasn't even part of the
known investigation right the gates
bringing new
elements uh into presenting derogatory
evidence about himself uh during
interviews
further matt gates said just look at my
congressional
travel records they're going to
exonerate me now
when matt gates refers to his
congressional travel records by
definition
his congressional travel records would
only refer to his
official travel the disclosures that
gates
filed with the house ethics committee
and the federal election commission
regarding his official trips
don't include the stuff that he was
talking about on fox news
on fox news he said check the records
we're going to provide them
they provided them but it's only his
official travel the the documents that
gates put out
don't include who traveled with gates
on a personal basis on the trips they
don't include
what payments did gates make for other
people to travel with him
personally not as part of his official
congressional
travel reservations and um
there's all sorts of trips that he made
to las vegas to yale university
university where anybody could have gone
with him and he might have paid for it
personally it wouldn't show up in
congressional travel records
we would have no idea about it so again
by raising the issue of travel records
he raises more questions about his
personal travel spending
who he paid for trips for did they cross
state lines how old were they
etcetera etcetera etcetera then
gates claims he's being extorted
over supposedly bogus fraudulent
investigations by the fbi that was his
claim his dad is being extorted he's
being extorted okay
that puts the spotlight on the
investigations and we realize hold on a
second
these investigations are more serious
and far more broad ranging than we
initially thought
matt gates might have done even more bad
stuff
than what we initially believed so the
more we learn
every time gates tries to assert his
innocence
the worse it gets and the worse we
suspect his actions of actually being
now
of course he's innocent until proven
guilty there's no question about that
you know every time we talk about uh
stories like this um
i'll get emails from right winger saying
do you not believe in innocent until
proven guilty yeah we do
we're reporting on allegations we report
on allegations when they're against
democrats and people on the left we're
talking about what the investigation is
looking at
we're talking about how every time he
opens his mouth he seems more guilty
of course you are innocent strictly
speaking you're innocent until
until proven guilty there's no no doubt
and he deserves a lawyer
and a defense and all of that stuff then
you add to this that gates was the only
vote in the house of representatives
against an anti-human trafficking bill
in 2017
that takes on a whole new meaning and
dimension based on what he's now accused
of
we've now learned that when matt gates
was in the florida legislature before he
was in the u.s house of representative
gates opposed a bill
meant to stop people from sharing what
we call revenge porn which is
sexually explicit images of
ex-relationships
because gates believed if you have those
images
from when you were in the relationship
those are yours to share
that takes on a whole new meaning in
light of the allegations about gates
sharing pictures with other members of
the house of representatives on the
house floor
this is the guy that wears his
membership
in the supposed party of family values
on his sleeve
and this is the reality that he's
actually living i would
love to see all of this come crashing
down
we have a poll that you can vote in
asking what do you think will be the
eventual outcome
of the matt gates scandal it's on our
youtube
community tab go to youtube.com the
david pakman show click on community
you can vote in the poll we'll have
results later this week and
of course we will publish those results
to our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show and if you want to
see the vacation picture i posted that
cost me
100 followers which isn't that much
actually
but okay i'm trying to be hyperbolic
here
the picture that cost me 100 followers
follow me on instagram
at david.pakman one of our sponsors is
privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial
is over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman